Please welcome Aasif Mandvi.
(audience cheer and clap)
Hi!
I love you.
It's been way too long.
Everybody, I'd like you
to see how long Aasif and I have known each other.
We go way back
to a film we did together called "Music and Lyrics."
I love that movie.
Which was apparently 15 years ago.
Was it?
Yeah, it seems like actually longer.
I don't know why, but in a good way.
No, I can't believe, it flies by.
It's just like, yeah.
I have such fond memories of that film.
Me too, we just had so much fun on that movie too.
It was such a great film.
I love Marc Lawrence, the Director, and Hughbert.
And Hugh, he was like a grumpy uncle.
Yes, yes!
You know what I mean?
You want him to be warm and fuzzy.
He's not, but then you end up falling in love
with the real Hugh.
He's so great.
He's very witty, very sharp.
But I remember I met him and I said,
it was some movie that he did
and I was like, "Did you have fun doing that movie?"
And he looked at me.
He was like, "Fun?
(Drew and audience laugh)
"Do you have fun?
"I don't think I ever have fun."
And I was like, "That's so Hugh."
I know, it's just too much.
Well, let's talk about your new show,
"Would I lie to you?"
Tell us about the show.
I've watched some of it.
Basically, it's based on a British show called,
"Would I lie to you?",
which has been on for like 14 years.
And we made the American version
and it's basically celebrities coming on and telling stories
from their life, which are personal, sometimes embarrassing.
And those stories, they read the card and that story
is either a lie or it's the truth about their life.
And they have to convince the other team
that's it's a lie if it's true and vice versa.
I wanna come on the show.
I wanna come
on the show too.
You should.
It's such a great concept.
It's so funny.
And we got great people
who were telling just outrageous stories.
Well, I think this show's gonna be really fun for people.
It's a lot of fun.
It's on The CW.
It's really exciting.
You have great guests
(audience cheer and clap)
and get us next season, we wanna do it.
(upbeat music)